good morning and welcome to playtime
2018 thank you for joining us today who
recognizes this haha couple days ago I
heard that Android Market was launched
almost to the date ten years ago I saw
some show of hands how many people had
an app on Android Market wow that's
awesome
I joined four years later when Play just
got launched it was a simpler time but
one with lots of uncertainties I
remember having conversations with lots
of you in this room and wondering will
people ever pay for apps and games on
Android
remember those conversations and
playtime was a small group of us in a
conference room at Google Mountain View
look how far we have come today together
we have built a thriving multi-billion
dollar industry you have identified
needs we did not even think existed and
created new markets for self-driving
sorry ride-sharing
and our self-driving yet for ride ship
for ride sharing hunting pokemons
for finding customized fitness etc and
we have spent a lot of time actively
listening to you to understand how to
build products and programs to meet you
need I was really pleased that you feel
heard
in a recent developer satisfaction study
you told us that you recognized your
input in the products and programs were
built I love it so we are really
grateful for the active dialogue that
we've been having together and want to
continue that so that we can build more
amazing apps and games and thriving
businesses so today I want to start
with a focus on the user users care
about three key things and I think we
need to partner on all of them at
quality safety and Trust and digital
well-being so let's start with app
quality in this room you represent the
highest quality apps and games so thank
you for your investment you also realize
that your investments have returns your
users spend more time and money but also
recommend your apps to other people we
know that ensuring high quality for
everybody is hard and users sometimes
are unforgiving we see a 52% increase in
1 star rating
when a user experiences a crash
therefore we've been investing in a set
of tools called Android Y tools to help
you measure quality in the field and
address them but you've told us it's one
thing to give me data make it actionable
I want to stand here and say we have
heard you today they're going to link
the pre-launch report to Android vitals
to make sure you get more actionable
insights more will be said about this in
classroom sessions and other quality
related sessions or please attend those
I'm also pleased to let you know that we
are going to use quality and long term
engagement signals in our search and
discovery algorithms so thank you for
your investment in quality we also do a
ton of work behind the scenes every app
goes through an extensive security
review and 99% of the apps that have any
abusive content it's never seen by the
user
it's taken out even
for the very first install after an app
has been installed Google Play protect
continues to monitor the app and to make
sure that it behaves well if it finds
that the app isn't it will either notify
you or take the app away to ensure that
your device is safe we scan 50 billion
apps a day 50 billion apps a day so it's
not surprising that a user who installs
an app exclusively from playing is 9
times less likely to come across a
harmful app than somebody who doesn't
but we can't do this alone
we really can't we need you to partner
with us on this very very important area
of user safety and trust our goal is to
make sure that users understand how
their data is used and that access is
reasonable last week we announced that
we are going to change access to SMS and
call log api's I'm sure you've heard it
we wanted to make sure that the apps
that use these api's absolutely need
them we could not have done it without
you we spoke to lot of you and took your
feedback before we made the changes your
input allows us to strike that right
balance between meeting user needs and
enabling you to have and build unique
experiences I want to stand here and
show you that we will have more such
conversations but also give you
sufficient notice to make this changes
you know that as of November 1st
hopefully everybody does
that all new apps and updates should
target API 26 every bit of it yes okay
it's a few days away all right so this
is important because it makes the user
safer but also improves battery life for
all your apps now we announced this ten
months ago and we gave very clear
guidance on how to comply that is how we
will continue to engage with you so
please work with us my one request is
for you to keep on top of this how many
of you know whether the contact
information on on our Play console is
up-to-date I see I would expect
everybody to put your hands up if you
don't please do also look up our
newsletters and please engage with us
when we ask for feedback I want to thank
everybody who responded to our recent
developer satisfaction study and hope to
have continued this dialogue going
forward so stay in touch and please
update your contacts we know that safety
security quality have always been
important to our users but recently
people have been thinking a lot about
striking that right balance between
using technology and disconnecting this
is me for me it's about spending time
with family being outside I love to
travel and be in nature at Google we've
spent a lot of time thinking about this
well-being
and at aureole we launched something
called as the digital well-being
initiative we have incorporated a bunch
of capabilities directly into android
key and we're giving a dashboard to
users to understand their digital usage
and also set controls they can set time
limits they can set time to win down
shush etc as businesses you and I have a
responsibility to respect our developers
our users time we frequently see that
apps that respect users time have higher
long-term engagement today we want to
invite you into the dialog because many
of you have been thinking about this
deeply for a very long time this evening
I'll be hosting a fireside chat with
Arianna Huffington to start this
dialogue on this topic of long-term
sustainable engagement and our
responsibility as businesses she'll also
share some personal tips on how we can
work together for our own sustained
performance and well-being your own most
of your leaders your own sustained
performance and that being so I hope
that all of you will continue to engage
on these three very important topics of
quality safety and Trust and digital
well-being now to talk about the many
other features that we have been working
on based on your feedback I'm inviting
onstage Matt Henderson
[Music]
Thanks tournament and hi everybody so my
team and I build play developer products
like the play console and today I'd like
to talk more about some play tools that
can help fuel your growth today you'll
hear about the tremendous potential of
our new smarter model for app
distribution we'll be talking about
features that help you attract new users
and also tools that help you to monetize
and grow your business so average app
size has grown dramatically it's up
three times in the last four years but
that size growth carries a cost it
reduces install conversion and it
increases uninstall rates so this is why
we built the Android app bundle we
announced it earlier this year at i/o
using it we're able to serve only the
code and resources that a specific
device needs and this enables you to
reduce the size of your app well since
we launched it just a short time ago
thousands of Android app bundles have
reached production all over the world
we're really excited with how it's
progressing and although the size
savings varies from app to app on
average we're seeing a 35 percent
reduction in the size which is terrific
we're really excited for the potential
of this you're going to hear more about
the bundle and the other benefits of
smaller apps and the possibilities with
modular apps at the session right after
this one so in addition to bundling and
distributing apps we've also introduced
new features to help you attract and
engage users and one of these is
pre-registration so we've had
pre-registration in testing for some
time now and it lets you gather interest
from users before your app or game is
released in order to produce
higher so day one installs it gathers up
the demand for that for that initial
launch and since we started testing it
we've had more than 250 million
pre-registrations which is awesome and
we're just getting started and today I'm
excited to announce that
pre-registration is available to all of
our app and game partners and it's fully
self-service in the Play console so
developers also now with
pre-registration they have the ability
to provide a promotion that rewards
people for signing up their interest
early and we think that's why got great
potential as well and additionally we've
integrated the Google Play instant
experience so this can let a user get a
taste of your Apple game prior to it
actually being ready and available to to
install and you can see an example of
this here with the Looney Tunes world of
mayhem it's the one on the left so it's
it we really think that it's going to
help provide enough of a taste that more
and more people will get into this
pre-launch
interest mode so Google Play Instant it
also now supports premium apps and
there's an example on the right the
Amero by devolver digital with instant
we've also made it easier to build with
integrations into Koko's creator and a
unity plugin is now available also
Google Play instant drives incremental
installs because people get enough of a
taste of it that they want more and they
want to install it we also have another
new launch that helps to increase
install conversion from the detail page
so one of the top requests from
developers has been the ability to
modify store listing pages based on user
country not just language well now you
can let's walk through an example in
this example so Halloween in the US and
Diwali in India they're about a week
apart
very different events and users in both
countries tend to have their devices set
to us English so now with Country Store
listing targeting you can change the
store listing content based on the
user's country so here for a to users
that have their device set to us English
not only are the icons and photos
different for this recipe app in this
example but also the description talks
about different festivals and different
features that may be important in each
country we think this has great
potential and now we've covered features
that are going to help bring users into
your app let's talk about helping you
grow your business so our commerce
platform makes it easy for people to
safely purchase on play in over 150
markets by a credit card direct Calliope
carry billing PayPal and gift cards and
the gift cards are now available in more
than 800,000 locations worldwide
it also supports various models like
premium apps in-app purchasing and
subscriptions and subscriptions our
features continue to expand we're
testing the ability for example for a
user to subscribe directly from your
store listing page from the same button
as they choose to install we're also
testing the ability to let users
temporarily pause a subscription instead
of canceling in and we're now making it
easier for you to roll out a price
change to your existing subscribers you
may recall at i/o we announced we were
starting to test with early access the
ability for a price change to be to be
notified out to existing suppliers
well now we're extending that to general
availability you can learn more about
these features and how they help your
subscriptions business in a session
later today along with strong growth and
subscriptions we're seeing more
developers use a hybrid approach to
monetization so one trend has been to
reward
users for a specific action like
watching a video and the reward can be
in-game currency or other benefits today
we're excited to announce a new
monetization type called rewarded
products users can elect to watch a
short video and upon completion they're
rewarded by the developer in virtual
goods or in-game currency this offering
is powered by Google Ads
technology and the implementation uses
the same IP API calls that are used for
in-app purchases on Google no
third-party SDK is required for this so
we're currently testing this in closed
beta but we'll share more details in the
coming weeks we've covered quite a bit
but as you know there's many more a huge
range of features that are available in
play and it can be tricky for you and
your teams to understand them all so to
help you take advantage of all the tools
and features that we offer we're
launching the Academy for app success
today there are 10 courses that have
information ranging from managing the
apps release to granting refunds going
forward will support more languages and
we're going to be adding more content to
help you and your teams to take
advantage of all of the features that
play has to offer so we really hope that
you check it out we've talked about some
new tools for growth on mobile but I
wanted to also touch on the broader
device landscape so as you know we
continue to push your apps out to more
devices with where OS Android TV Android
auto and across all surfaces with the
assistant today I'd like to focus on
Chrome OS hopefully you heard last week
we launched an exciting new device the
Google pixel slate it's a great example
of our investment in the Chrome OS
ecosystem and I'd like to explain how
that growing ecosystem is an exciting
opportunity for developers
in just a few years Chromebooks has gone
from a fun experiment to being available
throughout the world they range from
traditional laptops to convertibles and
they're created in partnership with top
OMS like Samsung HP Dell and others
they're now available in more than
10,000 retail locations around the world
and we continue to expand the made by
Google pixel slave is designed to bring
games and apps to life with brilliant
entertainment and portable performance
let's take a closer look at a couple of
great app experiences optimized for
Chromebooks and the pixel slave so
Gameloft wanted asphalt 8 airborne to
give users more speed and control and
since the Chrome OS treats its physical
keyboard like an external keyboard on
Android phone Asheville eight was able
to support keyboard controls using api's
from Android SDK 26 as a result for
users on Chrome OS Asheville I saw a
whopping 6 times increase in daily
active users and a nine times increase
in revenue the Gameloft team was excited
about the strong results and so
optimizing for larger screens has become
a standard practice and they've just
finished optimizing the latest edition
in their series Asheville 9 legends so
Evernote is another great example of
Chrome OS integration the Evernote team
was excited to use the low latency
stylus API to quickly implement
touchscreen handwriting and enhance
layouts for wider screens now without
the latency their users feel like they
are actually just drawing on paper which
is an awesome experience and as a result
the average Evernote user now spends 3
times more on larger screen devices and
four times more time when they're using
the Google picture book
so another great app for creators is
Adobe Premiere Rush it's a new video
platform that will allow people to
create to edit and share videos on the
go and the best part it's coming soon to
Chromebooks so these developers went
beyond a mobile only strategy they
adapted their products to serve users on
a variety of devices and as a result
they got increased engagement from users
the same may be true for you
Android apps are now available on Chrome
OS so you can take your app and with
just a few adjustments optimize it for
larger screens and if you want to get
your hands on a slate look for the
chrome booth outside there's a rumor
going around that they have a bunch of
slates so check them out so that's it
from me today there's lots of awesome
stuff to come thanks very much